hello
right about now I imagine you're asking
yourself who I am and why I'm here
to the first you can refer to me as
Black Box
to the second
it's really quite simple
our world has been through an
astronomical event
in what felt like the blink of an eye
half of our Earth's population
disappeared
and five years later it returned
but in the face of that we found no
answers
outside of a podcast Ran by A minor
league Avenger there was no one in a
position of authority coming forward
with an explanation
there were no government officials
telling us what was going on and any
attempts to use the Freedom of
Information Act resulted in us being
stonewalled tied up in court red tape
and to be quite Frank
it makes me sick
and so if those in positions of
authority refused to be transparent
refused to give us the information that
we deserve
then I will make them
and so what I'm about to tell you here
will seem far-fetched maybe even insane
but I promise you
it is all 100 true
at this very moment there is a man
walking around this world who cannot die
the man that I'm referring to has never
been photographed or captured on video
and those who have seen him are either
dead
or they refuse to speak his name
but information has recently come to me
that has been able to shed some light on
the man that they call the Wolverine
by now most of you know about Hydra
for those who don't the simple
explanation is that Hydra started as the
science division of the Germans during
World War II
they were believed to have been defunct
by the war's end but thanks to the
information done regarding Shield's
files we now know that Hydra had
secretly been taking over and running
Shield prior to its collapse
what you don't know is that during the
time when Hydra was in control of Shield
they secretly operated a program
known as Weapons Plus
now I doubt any of you have heard of
this project and it was believed to have
been started in the 1940s but nobody
knows for sure
what is important here is that after
Captain America was gone Hydra wanted to
make their own version
but with cap out of the picture and the
super soldier formula nowhere to be
found
Hydra had to start from scratch
and so if Captain America was the basis
behind their attempt to create a new
super soldier
then their first attempt could be called
weapon one
you know him as the Winter Soldier
now if you've been watching the news for
any real measure of time you already
know who the Winter Soldier is and so
there's no real need for an explanation
here
on the other hand weapons two through
nine are a bit more murky
there are rumors that some of these
weapons had names like project Sentry
but again information on this is hard to
verify
what we do know is that in the 1960s
that in addition to the Winter Soldier
Hydra secretly operated a wet work team
through the CIA
the group was known as team X and to put
it simply
these guys were the best there was at
what they did
these guys toppled governments they
killed dictators and there's even rumors
that they were loaned to Russia in order
to build a training regimen for their
black widow program
now according to my sources Hydra
eventually brought team X into weapons
plus as their 10th attempt to create
super soldiers with the Weapon X Program
and unlike previous programs weaponics
use a combination of artificial memory
plants physical enhancements and gene
therapy
now the process of artificial memory
implants allowed Hydra to create a
literal life of lies to ensure
compliance at every level
as far as physical enhancements were
concerned up until recently we didn't
know what enhancements had been made
but thanks to my contacts we know that
in the 1950s Hydra had become aware that
vibranium deposits existed in places
outside of the kingdom of wakanda
specifically these deposits were in the
Atlantic Ocean
now for reasons that remain unexplained
Hydra abandoned their drilling efforts
shortly after starting but they were
able to secure a sample
using this limited sample hydra's R D
division was able to blend vibranium
with several other elements of unknown
composition
and indeed the formula for this new
metal Still Remains a mystery the only
thing we know is that Hydra called this
new metal adamantium
this ultimately brings us to the gene
therapy process
prior to her death I made contact with
Dr Carol Hines one of the lead
scientists on the webinx program
she refused to identify her colleagues
but she did reveal that as part of the
program each member was screened for
genetic abnormalities I was told this
was a routine process and that according
to Dr Carol Hines Hydra had discovered
that the Man known as The Wolverine
contained a gene that did not match any
known database when this Gene was
activated it appeared to Grant a healing
Factor now according to Dr Hines this is
the reason why the Wolverine was the
only survivor of the adamantium bombing
process after this all we know and for
reasons that Dr Heinz would not reveal
somehow The Wolverine escaped and his
whereabouts had been unknown ever since
now again I know this seems like
something preposterous
I know this seems nonsensical
but I think it's important to bring this
information to you whether you choose to
believe it or not
because I believe that we as the people
of this Earth
we deserve the right to make the most
informed decision about this planet that
we possibly can
we deserve to have this information
and we deserve to know what's going on
and so this is Black Box signing off
make sure you stay vigilant
and to make sure you stay safe